donc
nous nettoyons l'environnement en
éliminant tous ces déchets et nous
les convertissons en énergie sous forme
de diesel sous forme d'essence sous forme de
gaz chaque jour nous traitons
1,5 tonne
de déchets chaque jour
ne vous inquiétez pas
le  le gaz que nous produisons l'essence
que nous produisons le diesel que nous
produisons est d'un
coût bien inférieur ou le coût de production est tellement
inférieur au diesel et à l'essence normaux
que vous obtenez de vos stations-service
c'est-à-dire que je
Je ne peux pas utiliser le carburant que je ne
connais pas exactement
et à partir des pneus,
je ne pense pas que cela puisse être le bon
carburant, sauf utiliser le carburant de ma voiture
tant qu'ils certifient correctement que cela
peut fonctionner, il n'y a pas de problème.  une
très bonne initiative qui est la
bienvenue
[Musique]
vous